[Music]
studied on them
I will Digital Heavenly Creatures with
one citizen Silicon Graphics computer
one single box I think we actually still
have it like that and I think we as a
door stop now I think we use it they
keep the door open we've still got a
memorial door stop but that one's so
bloody expensive and it took us forever
to save up and buy and it was like there
was one computer and heavenly creatures
and now we've got probably four six or
seven thousand computers probably it
yeah it's a little bit bigger you know
up to how many creatures I've done some
horror movies and things and it you know
and I'd always we'd always done our own
effects I mean we don't you know we'd
done all of our special effects which
with all pro cilix and priscilla configs
and zombie stuff and all that but we had
done it ourselves and and you know and i
love it i love a fix I I never want to
give them to somebody else to do because
they've had the fun of filmmaking the
one event that happened as I is Jurassic
Park and literally just as we were
getting into a many creatures 1993 93 94
93 and and I'm and and I went to see
Jurassic Park and the Tyrannosaurus Rex
you know I really thought I'd I was
seeing a living breathing t-rex I just
thought oh my god yeah whatever the
future of our visual effects is it's got
to be computers you know people aren't
doing stop-motion dinosaurs or puppets
or anything else at CGI now all the way
and it was so good it was so incredible
so I you know I wanted to get into that
so for heavenly creatures with a 3-week
to tear that trees we didn't really need
any CGI in it film really but we use the
film as an excuse to buy one computer
just equally our toe in the water and we
had a guy who could figure out how to
work it and we've got a couple of bits
of software and we did the effects and
human creatures really just for the sake
of doing some CGI effects just so we did
actually start to figure it out and then
on the frighteners which was the next
movie we went from one computer heavenly
creatures we have 30 computers on that
movie so it was a pretty big pretty big
jump I remember the big nightmare for us
on that movie was to do cloth CGI cloth
because one of our characters was sort
of a repo Grim Reaper type guy with
flying black robes and so we had to do
CGI cloth you know at that point in time
I mean not you know it was it was never
really done though and here cloth was
one of the things that people hadn't
managed to figure out yet so we had code
writers you know you know writing up
code to do cloth for us and and when you
look at it today it's pretty pretty
crude it's pretty gnarly only it looks
like a stretchy plastic vinyl it doesn't
really look like cloth that's kind of
you know now it's just slightly you'd
buy a piece of software for very peanuts
that can do a baby the cloth now you
know it's um I mean I mean look we live
in an age where everything is possible
really and with computer CGI you know
there's nothing that you cannot imagine
in your head or read on a script or
whatever that you can't actually you
know do now you know when I was in the
old days when the old days when I'm
about 20 years ago when things were
starting out you know it was hard to do
water had had to do fear you know there
were certain sort of things that were
just not reesy
to do well but so now that's everything
that's possible so really what you're
what you've got now as you've somebody
got faster and cheaper terms of
computers you know every year they get
cheaper and they get twice as fast and
so when you're doing visual effects
that's like any form of filmmaking you
often want to take 2 take 3 take 4 you
know you do you do the fire shot with
all the flames once and you know you've
got to sit your CGI flames and you know
you know this is really gonna give it
looking great on the first type so it's
good even if they were sick and go and
maybe a third go maybe fourth go so so
when you actually got computers that are
getting quicker and faster you know it
gives you more goes at doing this stuff
so ultimately you get a bit of looking
result and you know if the result either
is something you can do with
off-the-shelf software I mean we use a
lot of just you know really available
you know not particularly expensive
often off-the-shelf programs but bits um
but occasionally you do get something
you would like to do and it's usually
involves water or you know splashing the
water or fire no that's sort of thing
but you know that you want to do
something that the off-the-shelf
software you know can't quite do mainly
weather I mean that you know you create
proprietary software when it's needed so
if you have an effect that needs to be
created and you can't achieve it through
what you brought off the shelf bought
off the shelf you will you know you'll
find other ways to do it and you've got
a team of great artists
great you know great technicians who who
will then you know whether it's pipeline
to try and make you know the whole the
whole workflow more efficient or whether
it's to actually solve a specific
storytelling problem that's when that
stuff comes you know starts us to sort
of self generate I know that we're
digital written about a hundred pieces
of code for a wide variety of different
things and it's sort of good it drives
me a little bit crazy because we keep
writing code for the same things every
time like we do avatar in a few years
ago when we wrote software to create
grass and you know trees leaves that can
blow and the wind also stuff and then I
you know I come along
in with the Hobbit and well and I want
some grass and some shots and some trees
so I can't no why can't we use the stuff
that we broke right trim it out ah no no
I mean it was fine for that film but we
want to be to be a better I mean there's
some sort of code and unspoken code
where you it's not not anything to do
with the ownership of the software
because it belongs to us we can
certainly use it but the guys themselves
they don't they want to do everything
better than they did last time so they
don't want the ever tie grass or the
leaves they want to do grass and leaves
bitter bitter that's something they said
about writing all new grass software all
new leaf software over and over again
all the times that they do you know the
result is actually better it a bit of
grass and so is so they are actually
right and so that extended in doing it
the first time around they they know how
to do it better the second time around
and they want the opportunity to do it
they want a film to do it with